supongamos que tenemos el vector a cuyas
componentes xy son lo voy a escribir
como vector columna la componente en x
es menos 10 y la componente en yes 7 y
como hemos visto hay varias maneras de
representar un vector lo podemos
escribir en términos de los vectores
unitarios a lo podemos escribir como
menos 10 que multiplica al vector
unitario en la dirección horizontal más
7 que multiplica al vector unitario en
la dirección vertical
ahora bien podemos dibujar este vector
tomando cualquier punto inicial si
tomamos el origen como punto inicial
como se vería este vector bien la
componente en x es menos 10 así es que
nos movemos 10 unidades hacia la
izquierda y la componente ni el 7 así es
que nos movemos 10 a la izquierda y 7
hacia arriba para llegar a este punto y
el vector se va a ver así su punto
inicial es el origen mientras que su
punto final inicia en el origen y su
punto terminal corresponde al punto
cuyas coordenadas son x igual a menos 10
igual a 7
así es que aquí tenemos una manera de
representar el vector a vamos a mover
este vector un poco queremos tener un
punto terminal distinto supongamos
entonces que en vez de tener el punto
terminal menos 10 7
queremos que el punto terminal sea el
punto t de coordenadas 3,535 mejor
hagamos que éste sea menos 3 así es que
este es el punto terminal menos 35
podemos imaginar cómo se vería el vector
si trasladamos este punto terminal aquí
se vería más o menos así aquí tenemos la
punta del vector
ubicada en el punto terminal y el vector
iniciar ya no sé más o menos en esta
zona que tenemos acá por lo pronto no
sabemos dónde exactamente si pudiéramos
copiar y pegar este vector podríamos
ubicar el punto preciso después de
trasladar el vector aquí en la gráfica
pero en vez de hacer eso veamos si
podemos calcularlo matemáticamente
calculemos entonces matemáticamente cuál
es el punto inicial de este vector el
vector a una vez que trasladamos el
punto terminal al punto t de coordenadas
menos 3.5
entonces que el punto inicial que
queremos conocer es el punto y cuyas
coordenadas son x inicial coma y inicial
x subíndice y coma
el subíndice y como hacemos entonces a
partir del punto inicial y el punto
terminal para obtener las componentes
del vector tienen la componente en x del
vector va a corresponder al cambio en x
yendo del punto inicial al punto
terminal mientras que la componente en y
va a ser el cambio en la dirección de y
desde el punto inicial al punto terminal
tenemos entonces que la componente en x
del vector menos 10 es igual al cambio
en x del punto inicial al punto terminal
es decir la coordenada en x del punto
terminal menos tres menos la coordenada
en x del punto inicial - x subíndice y
de la misma manera la componente en ye
del vector que es 7 es igual al cambio
en ye del punto inicial al punto
terminal es decir la componente en y del
punto terminal que es 5 menos la
componente en 10 del punto inicial
subíndice y ahora de estas ecuaciones ya
podemos despejar la x inicial y la ye
inicial
veamos cómo hacemos esto si
multiplicamos por menos 1 esta ecuación
tenemos que 10 es igual 10 es igual
multiplicamos por menos 1 también el
lado derecho de la ecuación para obtener
vamos a obtener x y x psuv y más
precisamente x psuv y más 3
ahora restando 3 a ambos lados de la
ecuación vamos a tener que x putts este
no es el color x subíndice y es igual a
10 menos 37 ahora despejemos ya subí de
esta ecuación si multiplicamos ambos
lados de la ecuación por menos 1
obtenemos que menos 7 es igual
y el subíndice y
- 5 ahora sumando 5 ambos lados
obtenemos que ye subíndice y es igual a
menos 2 entonces las coordenadas del
punto inicial dado que tenemos como
punto terminal menos 35 para este vector
a estas van a ser las coordenadas del
punto inicial y van a ser x igual a 7 y
de igual a menos 2
veamos si hace sentido gráficamente
tenemos que x es igual a 7 y es igual a
menos 2 ese es el punto inicial así es
que nuestro vector nuestro vector se va
a ver
así es es ahora nuestro vector lo cual
viendo la gráfica hace sentido es el
vector original que teníamos con el
punto inicial en el origen el cual hemos
trasladado lo trasladamos hacia abajo
dos unidades y a la derecha uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete unidades y aquí
lo tenemos ahora ya estamos bien
equipados y conocemos el punto inicial y
terminal de un vector podemos conocer
sus componentes xy o si conocemos el
punto terminal y los componentes xy
podemos conocer el punto inicial o si
conocemos las componentes xy el punto
inicial podemos conocer el punto
terminal
si conoces cualesquiera de estos dos
elementos puedes conocer el tercero